اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اهتمامه بالخطه الصينيه لوقت الحرب في
اوكرانيا واضاف لدى استقباله نظيره الصيني
شي جينلينج في موسكو ان لدى بلاده الكثير
من المهام والاهداف المشتركه مع الصين
بدوره وصف شيع علاقه بلاده مع روسيا
بالشراكه الاستراتيجيه واكد ضروره
تعاونهما لتحقيق الاهداف المتعلقه
بالعداله والمساواه في العالم حسب قومه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ماء
فوق العلاقه صينيه الروسيه وامكانيه
تطورها الى تعاون الاستراتيجي وما نقاط
التوافق والخلاف بين البلدين فيما يتعلق
بالموقف من الغرب
وما هي انعكاسات التقارب الصيني الروسي
على مسار الحرب في اوكرانيا وما الحدود
التي يمكن ان تبلغها جهود التعاون العسكري
بين الجانبين
وكيف سيتعامل الغرب مع تطور العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه والنتائج التي قد تترتب
على هذا التقارب بين موسكو وبيجين
وانعكاسه على القرار الدولي
[موسيقى]
في اول زياره خارجيه له منذ اعاده انتخابه
للمره الثالثه رئيسا لبلاده وصل الرئيس
الصيني يوم الاثنين الى موسكو حيث استقبله
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الزياره التي
ستستمر ثلاثه ايام والتي ستشهد بحسب
الكريم توقيع اتفاقيات عده خاصه في مجال
التعاون الاقتصادي افتتح الزعيمان بتاكيد
استراتيجيه العلاقه بين بلديهما واهميه
تعونهما من اجل ما سمياه اعاده التوازن
للنظام العالمي وبينما رحب بوتين بخطه
ضيفه لوقت الحرب في اوكرانيا اكد شيء
اهتمام الصين بتطوير علاقتها بروسيا التي
وصفها بالشريك الاستراتيجي الذي يشارك
بلاده اهدافا متشابهه تتعلق بالعداله
والمساواه في العالم
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من ميريلاند
تشارلي عضو مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه
الصادق وكبير الباحثين في مجلس العلاقات
الخارجيه بواشنطن ومن موسكو معنى دكتور
الكسندر جورنو الاستاذ في مهدي موسكو
للصحافه الدوليه
ابدا معك
باي عين تنظر الولايات المتحده الى هذه
الزياره زياره الرئيس الصيني الى موسكو
والحديث عن الشراكه والتعاون والاهداف
المشتركه لكلا البلدين على المستوى
العالمي
اعتقد ان المنظور الامريكي من واشنطن
مفاده انها زياره مهمه بالنسبه الى بوتين
لاسيما بعد ان وجهت اليه التهمه من قبل
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بارتكاب جرائم
حرب زياره هذه زياره زياره الدوله الرسميه
والكثير من التنه والرنه كلها تشير الى ان
الصين تريد ان تدعم شركتها مع روسيا وان
تستمر بدعم روسيا
والتجاره معها وشراء منتجات الطاقه
الروسيه وهذا سوف يساهم في استمرار الحرب
لانه يدعم الاقتصاد الروسي في الوقت نفسه
يظهر ذلك ان الصين تريد ان تحاول
الاقتراع بدور اكبر في مجال دبلوماسيه
الدوليه حيث انها
توسطت
لاتفاق لعدد بناء العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران وقدمت مقترحا لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اذا يريد شيئا يبدو كما ان يبدو
كما لو انه شخص مؤثر عالميا ويدفع باتجاه
السلام ما الذي يرجع عن هذا الاجتماع هل
هي هدنه اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الى ما
هنالك تبقى الامور مشكوكا بها ولكن سوف
ننتظرها لتتبلور في الايام المقبله
ولكن الا يثبت الرئيس الصيني انه قادر
على ان يكون مؤثرا فعلا في المنطقه وانه
كما بدا يقال بدا يسحب البساط من تحت
الولايات المتحده
ان الصين قد تفاجات الى حد ما
بالدرجه التي تدهورت فيها سمعتها لاسيما
بعد جائحه كورونا وكذلك نتيجه الدعمها
لروسيا في حرب يراها معظم العالم
كاعتداء سافر واعتقد ان الصين الانيه
تحاول ان تعود عما خسيرته من سمعتها هل
نحن الان نعيش في عالم تحاول فيه الصين ان
تكمل
تاثيرها الاقتصادي من خلال الضغط
الدبلوماسي نعم طبعا ولكن طبعا مع
توسع رقعه الصين الاقتصاديه سوف تحاول ان
تؤثر السياسيا اعتقد اننا وصلنا الى مرحله
جديده ستحاول فيها الصين ان تضغط
دبلوماسيا بانتظامنا اكبر اين ذلك في دول
الخليج ونرى ذلك اليوم مع هذا الزياره
الكبيره الى موسكو هذا هو العلم الجديد
الذي نعيش فيه سيد الكسندر
هل نقاط التوافق بين روسيا والصين تكفي
لبناء تعاون استراتيجي ليس فقط على
المستوى
الاقتصادي وتعاون في بعض القضايا الدوليه
لكن تعاون استراتيجي وشراكه استراتيجيه
خصوصا في مواجهه الخصوم
كما كما يعتبر الغرب والولايات المتحده
شكرا اولا على سؤالكم وشكرا لاستضافتي
اولا علي
ان اعلق سمعنا ان الغالبيه من العالم
يدين روسيا ليس الغالبيه
الغالبيه من حلفاء الوقت المتحده يدينون
روسيا وهؤلاء يشكرون قليه في العالم وليس
اغلبيه روسيا والصين تشكلان الغالبيه في
العالم اليوم العالم بدا يصبح متعدده
القطبيه وليس كما كان مهيمنا عليه من
الولايات المتحده سالتم عن الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه حقيقه
الزعيم الصيني الصيني قال ان روسيا هي
الشريك الاستراتيجي الوحيد الشريك
الاستراتيجي الوحيد في العالم بالمناسبه
روسيا لديها عدد من
الشركاء الاستراتيجيين بما فيهم معظم
بلدان الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق لكن وزير الخارجيه الروسي اكد على
ان العلاقات الروسيه والصينيه هي باعلى
مستوياتها كما كانت عليه في طوال عصور
التاريخ والعلاقات بين الصين وروسيا جيده
منذ القرن السابع عشر والتي والذي شهد
توقيع اول اتفاقيه بين روسيا والسنغال
هناك خلفيه تاريخيه لهذا علاقه ومستقبل
لها ايضا لكن هل
سياسيا
تتطابق المواقف الصينيه والروسيه
لتشكل حلفا استراتيجيا وهذا هو السؤال
المحور الان المطروح
ما سمعناه اليوم من الزعيم الشيخ
وتوتن ومن خلال بداء الاول
بدايات اللقاء بينهما الذي شاهدناه على
شاشات التلفزه ومن خلال
[موسيقى]
في نشرته الصحفي في زر الجبال وفي غازيتا
الروسيه راينا ان موقفي الزعيمان وخاصه
فيما يتعلقوا في مجال العلاقات الدوليه
متشابهه الى حد كبير وادوا ان نقتبس من
كلام السيد توتنه الذي قال الاتي نحن نسمن
كثيرا
سعيكم من اجل
احقاقي القانون الدولي
وايضا تعزيزي الامن وايضا
سعيكم لكي يكون هناك عالم اكثر انصافا
وعدلا وعلاقات اكثر انصافا علينا ان نشدد
ايضا على ان
البلدان
سيوقعان وثيقتان مهمتين للغايه وذلك غدا
احداهما تسمى
الشراكه في عالم جديد يتغير مفاهيم
مفاهيمه والاخر يتعلق بالتعاون الاقتصادي
لعشر وثائق اخرى
ان اعود الى السيد كابتشين في هذه النقطه
سيد كابتشن قلت بوضوح ان هذا هو العلم
الجديد الذي الذي نراه لكن هذا العلم
الجديد الا ترى انه يبنى على حساب قوه
الولايات المتحده
ونفوذ الولايات المتحده في العالم
يعني بحيث اننا امام قطب مشترك يواجه
الولايات المتحده والغرب
بشكل ندي
انا اعتقد ان العلاقه بين روسيا والصين هي
بصوره اساسيه
ذات طابعات جيو سياسيه وان الشياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا
يعيدنا الى عالم فيه كتله لديك ديمقراطيات
الليبراليه من جهه ولديك روسيا وصين من
جهه اخرى وانا اوافق الزميل الضيف الروسي
ان الكثير من الدول في العالم لم تفرض
العقوبات لم تقم بانفادها لم تدن هذا
الاعتداء الروسي وفي الوقت نفسه واضح جدا
ان روسيا قد ارتكبت اعمالا عدائيه والديك
عدد كبير من دول
المتحده التي تقف الى جانب الديمقراطيات
انوه هنا بان النقطه الاولى من مقترح
السلام الذي خرج عن الصين منذ اسبوعين هو
السياده على الاراضي
اكتمال الاراضي وكذلك السيطره على الحدود
هل سوف يرغم بوتا على ذلك سيرغمها على
اعاده كافه الاقسام التي استولت عليها
روسيا من اوكرانيا لا وبالتالي اعتقد ان
هناك توتر اساسي بين دعوه الصين الى سياده
الدول على اراضيها وسلامه اراضيها وعدم
استعداد بطن الخروج من اوكرانيا نقطه
اضافيه لا اعتقد ان العلاقات بين روسيا
والصين هي بالقوه التي وصفها زميلنا الضيف
الروسي معظم التاريخ او تاريخ هذا العلاقه
يشير الى ان هناك الكثير من توترات كانت
اذا في خصومه خلال الحرب البارده اعتقد ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا قد قربتهما ولكنه زواج
مصلحه اكثر منه شراكه سوف تدوم طويلا زواج
مصلحه طيب في النقطه التي اشرت اليها وقد
سبقتني بالحديث عنها السيد كابشن اود ان
اتوجه الى صيد الكسندر فيما يتعلق
الخطه الصينيه للسلام الرئيس بوتين اشار
الى ان الى انه منفتح على هذه الخطه لكن
كما قال ضيفنا وكما هو معروف في هذه الخطه
هي تتحدث عن سياده
الدول على اراضيها وعلى حدودها كيف يمكن
ان يكون الرئيس بوتين منفتحا وهو لا يعترف
باراضي اوكرانيه وقد سبق انضمها الى بلاده
باختصار فقط ارجوك
اولا الرئيس بوتين
صدق الله القول ان روسيا معنى في التدقيق
في الخطه الروسيه
والمقاربه الروسيه مشابهه كثيرا الى تلك
التي تضمنتها مذكره روسيا في ديسمبر 2021
قبل ما حدث في اوكرانيا وانا اتذكر ان
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
اقترحت مذكره للبدء
بمحاوله لحل الموقف بين روسيا وحلف الناتا
واوكرانيا وما الى ذلك اذا اعتقد ان خطه
السلام قد تنجح وقد تشكل نقطه بدايه
لعمل جاد من اجل
تعزيزي الاستقرار زميلنا في الولايات
المتحده قال ان الخطه
المتحده ليست سعيده من خطه السلام الصينيه
نحن راينا في العقود الماضيه ان الولايات
المتحده لم تكن سعيده باي خطه ليس مصدرها
الولايات المتحده اما ما تفعله روسيا في
اوكرانيا نحن بالطبع نسال ماذا تفعل وانت
المتحده في سوريا
الجنود الامريكيون في سوريا ولا احد اوجه
لهم الدعوه
الكسندر حتى لا نشعب الحديث سيد الكسندر
سيد الكسندر حتى حتى حتى حتى لا يتشعب
الحديث لكن فقط في النقطه المتعلقه بالخطط
الصينيه انا سالتك بوضوح الخطه تتحدث عن
سياده الدول هل تستعد
هل روسيا مستعده لان تعترف بسياده
اوكرانيا على اراضيها ارجوك باختصار اجبني
على هذه النقطه لكي انتقل الى
روسيا مستعده للنظر في وضع اوكرانيا كدوله
ذات سياده اذا كانت المتحده لا تنظر في
مساله اوكرانيا كدوله
لان الاوكرانيا هي مستعمره لامريكا اذا
خرجت منها امريكا ستخرج منها روسيا لا
مشكله في ذلك
يعني الاجابه ملتبسه صراحه وغير مفهومه
بشكل دقيق يعني واضح ان هناك تهرب من هذه
النقطه من الجانب الروسي تجاه الخطه
الصينيه سيد تشارليس
هل تعول الولايات المتحده على بنود الخطه
الروسيه للسلام في اوكرانيا
بناء على ما تفضل به ضيف الروسي ليس هناك
اي جنود امريكيين امريكيون ولا من حلف
شمال الاطلسي في اوكرانيا اوكرانيا تحاول
ان تتصدى لوحدها او من خارج هذه الدول
وبالنظر الى ذلك يجب على اوكرانيا ان
تستمتع بسعادتها على اراضيها وبسلامه
اراضيها وعلى روسيا الانسحاب اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده ستقبل نوع من الجهود من
اجل انهاء الحرب دبلوماسيان قال الرئيس
الامريكي اكثر من مره ان الهدف هو ان تكون
اوكرانيا في اقوى موقف ممكن في او على
طاوله المفاوضات ولكن روسيا بحاجه الى ان
تكون مستعده لاحترام سياده اوكرانيا على
اراضيها يجب ان تتوقف روسيا عن اجتياح
اوكرانيا وقصفها وقتل ابنائها اذا تمكنت
الصين من ان تقنع روسيا بانهاء الحرب وان
تنسحب وانتجس الى طاوله المفاوضات في خلال
التوصل الى اتفاق حول انهاء الحرب نهائيا
اعتقد ان واشنطن سوف ترحبان بذلك ولكن لم
نتحدث الى الرئيس اوكراني زيلنسكي لم يوضح
انه فعلا مساعد للضغط على بوتين من اجل
البدء بالانسحاب من اوكرانيا والى حين
حصول ذلك اعتقد اننا سوف نشهد تشكيكا فعلا
في خطه الصين للسلام سواء في كييف او في
واشنطن اين يتواجد الجنود الامريكيون في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لهذه المناطق التي اصبحت تسال من روسيا
الان ولكن اوكرانيا حرب سيد الكسندر رجاء
رجاء باختصار التعاون العسكري عفوا عفوا
التعاون العسكري بين الولايات بين روسيا
والصين هل يمكن ان يتمظهر اكثر في ظل
الحرب المستمره في اوكرانيا باختصار شديد
يبدو انك لا تسمعني صيد الكسندر اعود الى
سيد تشارليز كابتشن الغرب كيف يمكن ان
يتعامل الولايات المتحده امام هذا الواقع
الجديد سيد كابتن هذا التقارب
يعني الى حد التطابق في المواقف بين روسيا
والصين سميته زواج مصلحه لكن في النهايه
هو يتكرس بتعاون استراتيجي اقله في
المرحله الحاليه كيف ستتعمل الولايات
المتحده والغرب مع هذا المستجد
وسوف حتى الان
اين هذا الزواج بين بيتين وموسكو كما
اسلفت قد ادى الى ما يبدو انه ظهور
لعلم بكتلتين وهذا ما يذكرنا بفتره الحرب
البارده مع مواجهه معسكره تجري على قدم
وساق وفي الوقت نفسه يبقى هناك هناك
اعتماد كبير على الاقتصاد الصيني ولدينا
اعمال والتجاره مع دوله روسيا والصين بما
فيه لما يتعلق
بمعالجات التغير المناخي الموضوع انتشار
سلاح النووي وغيره
اذا سوف يكون هناك عمل على نهائي هذه
الحرب قدر الامكان واعاده سياده سياده
اوكرانيا على اراضيها مع التفكير في ضروره
بناء علاقه بين
الصين لان الصين سوف يكون لديها اكبر
اقتصاد عالمي بنهايه هذا العقد شكرا
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]